non là c'est ce qu'on va faire si j'ai
menti on va les faire une interview
mensonge
un car les noms sont luis fernandez
serait très facile pour vous il suffit
de mentir et je pense que quand on a été
entraîneur du psg c'est pas difficile
dagorn depuis que vous êtes partie le
psg a gagné la coupe de france et a fait
deuxième du championnat est ce que ça
vous fait plaisir louise de voir ses
résultats
oui vous l'avez trouvé comment le jeu du
psg celle donnée très bon avec vous à la
tête de l'équipe est ce que le psg
aurait fait mieux
non vous êtes malheureux d'avoir dû
quitter paris luis oui vous pensez quoi
de votre successeur d'où vient que du
bien c'est un bon dr ah oui c'est vrai
qu'au psg il ya plus d'entraîneuse que
d'entraîneur oui est-ce que d'après vous
le psg peut être champion de france l'an
prochain
non quand vous avez annoncé au jdd que
vous aviez un plan pour reprendre le psg
c'était un mensonge
non vous raconter beaucoup de conneries
quand même ça m'arrive souvent mais là
tu mens pas vous vous sentez responsable
de l'échec avec ronaldinho oui vous
n'avez jamais eu envie de m'excuser
auprès des supporters du psg
oui pensez quoi des fachos du parc sens
un progrès ils s'entraident et longue à
venir et ça vous dirait un jour de
devenir entraîneur l'équipe de france
oui c'est de retourner au parc des
princes pour chanter non vous êtes
content d'être venu ce soir
non non
m